welcome back to las vegas now it's time
for today's legal minute and attorney
eric palacios from eric palacios and
associates sponsors of this segment
share the multiple ways one can go about
becoming a legal resident of the united
states take a look
hi i'm eric palacios and welcome to the
legal minute today's question is what
are the most common ways to become a
legal resident of the united states or
to get a green card number one through a
relative if you already have a relative
living legally in the united states your
relative can sponsor you a u.s citizen
can immediately sponsor a spouse
unmarried children under the age of 21
and their parents
number two through work if you have a
qualifying job offer if you're moving to
the united states for a permanent job
offer your employer can petition you for
residency
also immigrants who demonstrate an
exceptional ability don't need a sponsor
and they can petition themselves
number three if you're a refugee or an
acai lead if you are legally in the
united states as a refugee or through
asylum and have lived in the united
states for at least a year you can
petition for residency don't forget to
download my free app eric palacio's
legal app we'll see you next time
and for more information give eric
palacios and associates a call at
702-444-7777